oh
[Music]
[Music]
at this point you're probably wondering
how did they pull this off and what the
heck actually happened so today i'm
gonna break down exactly what happened
step by step because this brilliance
requires a lot more explaining than you
might think and maybe you'll appreciate
it even more when you see all the puzzle
pieces together if you enjoy these types
of breakdowns let us know with a like
user bren echo shared this clip on
twitter on may 5th of 2022 and dropped
many jaws there's a total of seven major
glitches used here all with different
properties that combine to make this
work perfectly so let's jump right in
and explain first what's happening on
link's side
this is a fairly recent find called
jelly bouncing a technique that uses a
normal choo choo jelly splash to push
link airborne if he breaks the jelly
perfectly beneath his feet enough to get
you bullet time you can trigger this by
dash attacking into the tutu jelly or
more consistently by performing a
charged spin attack over the jelly
launching you upwards for bullet time
attacks the interesting thing is in this
case since you're holding downwards to
move backwards during the spin attack
and being knocked airborne link
automatically backflips without even
touching the jump button this is
important for the next part tcr
tcr is also known as thunderclap rush a
technique that lets link flurry rush
whenever he wants while side hopping or
backflipping then by pressing zr and y
together you'll then manually force a
flurry rush and bullet time back to back
the standard flurry rush goes by marking
and chasing a system whereby dodging any
attack the mark is placed on the enemy
so that when link's feet touch the
ground you will flurry rush the enemy
pretty simple tcr forces this flurry
rush whenever you want but wait i didn't
move anywhere
well you have to mark the enemy first by
either blocking moving out of a way or
getting hit by a flurry rushable attack
first then the mark is placed on the
enemy and you can chase them down
whenever you want with your tcr
alright with that out of the way wait a
minute didn't you say you place a mark
from a flurry rushable attack you can't
flurry rush a guardian laser that's
impossible yes you're right technically
so let's next explain the clever tricks
behind what's going on on the guardian
side instead because there's a ton under
the hood that you never saw before this
clip even happened so how is link flurry
rushing through the guardian and
blasting him off into the sunset like
this let's first explain how to chase a
guardian's laser the way to trigger this
is to parry the laser with daruk's
protection in bullet time while locked
on the enemy
then it will be marked until the point
that it explodes this is how brad neko
starts his setup this kind of mark is
special staying in a specific location
rather than an enemy target called sdm
or slow daruk marking
[Music]
tcring while you have an sdm placed is
called an atr or absolute thunderclap
rush there's still one extra rule though
when you set the first sdm it can be
newly updated to a different position
when the guardian fires again where
their laser explodes next we'll place
the newly updated mark this visual shows
where you can manually place a point you
want to rush whenever you want
the second part after seems pretty basic
he's just walking to the side pretty
simple but even this is very specific as
well see the guardian needs to stay at
this exact location and cannot move for
this whole plan to come together so to
do that he has to stay at a very
specific distance to not trigger the
guardian to move
if you've ever fought one guardians know
how to be cheeky they have a small
proximity range to run away from you if
you're too close and chase after you if
you're too far but if you stay in its
mid-range its comfy spot it will stay
still
again this is very important as we'll
see later in the video swinging around
to the other side of the guardian while
staying at mid range he performs a
guardian disable
i've covered this before in one of my
things you didn't know videos where you
can basically lock a guardian into a
friendly state by using herbosis fury
then stasis this keeps the guardian
stationary and does not attack you this
is pretty useful by itself but it also
causes a multitude of other entertaining
and useful properties in this case
though the first useful property is that
for some reason it will auto fire at
link once while using rivali's gale
[Music]
but of course this can be used in your
favor because now your slow the rook
mark you set earlier has been updated to
a new location up in the air link will
still attempt to flurry rush of aerial
mark he'll just stop below the mid-air
mark
why does he want the mark here instead
of on the guardian well as you saw in
the clip flurry rushing link is pretty
much a speeding freight train and
basically cannot be stopped link's
flurry rushing body has so much momentum
a pile drives right through guardians
launching their rag dolling body into
the sunset this won't work as well if
you simply stop at the guardian itself
so this is why the mark is placed on the
other side of the guardian so link
rushes through the guardian not at the
guardian
the other thing guardian disabling does
is keep the guardian permanently loaded
no matter where you are in hyrule when
far enough away from certain objects
enemies and structures they will unload
and prioritize the game's memory to keep
it running smoothly pretty standard in
most video games but this trick keeps
the guardian loaded no matter what even
if you're literally on the other side of
hyrule such as the example here you can
see its health bar all the way from here
to van na boris
so let's do a quick recap you initiate
sdm with the guardian scoot around to
the other side disable and immobilize
the guardian which is now permanently
loaded no matter where you are in hyrule
and has a mark ready to go waiting above
it on the other side
[Music]
this is all really important because the
next step requires you to leave the
guardian and head to the temple of time
no shortcuts here because fast traveling
will undo everything you've just set up
so you'll have to hoof it over there in
this case though since it's 2022 players
use a technique called vlss or bow lift
smuggling slide to make this trip just a
tad easier we have a video explaining
blss in the video card above once
arrived this is where the second skill
set comes into play called trick
shotting players have optimized over the
years on how to perfectly line up an
arrow shot from literally miles away and
this is no exception he first pre-sets
up another blss ahead of time with a
held pot then he heads over to this very
specific set of rocks a location he
scouted beforehand that he knows that
will be a perfect location to draw his
ancient bow the longest ranged normal
bow in the game then he points up and
fires wait what how do you know where
you're shooting well i'll give you a
hint it's hard to do this during the
daytime that's right he's using the
stars to place his shot in the perfect
place you basically become an astronomer
becoming familiar with specific stars as
a reference to consistently have your
arrows fire in the spot that you want
from this point in very specific timing
and order we fire three arrows a bomb
arrow a normal arrow and an ancient
arrow these are all used in sequence for
a very specific reason you'll see why
soon as soon as the third arrow is fired
he climbs on the rock ledge and
initiates blss again to chase after his
own shot arrows now if you've ever seen
or performed this trick you know that
players wiggle for a bit to gain speed
and fly through the air at ridiculous
speeds even faster than an arrow can fly
why is your pointer skyward well for
loading prioritization
the camera will always prioritize what's
visible in front of it and less priority
on what's behind it this again is
important because if you don't keep your
eyes on the arrows and they get too far
away they have a risk of unloading and
disappearing mid-flight putting your
hard work to waste so then how do you
see where you're going all you see is
sky well that's why we got the minimap
so you have to perform this whole trick
and navigate back to the guardian as
fast as possible with precision using
your mini map to guide you and outpace
your own arrows you shot earlier once he
knows exactly where to stop he
disengages blss and starts gliding
downwards
now he's waiting for an audio cue the
first bomb arrow
now why a bomb arrow well when you
guardian disable several actions
including firing a bomb will unlock the
guardian back to its normal state
so first the bomb arrow arrives and
unlocks the guardian off screen to
become hostile again
but what this also does is turn the
guardian's head around so the next arrow
will strike its eye it's ingenious he
lands at the perfect distance again to
make sure the guardian doesn't back off
or chase after him then he immediately
casts magnesis and opens his menu this
does two things give him a second to go
back into pro mode and the options to
get rid of the mini map and prepare for
an epic moment and a second to hold a
chuchu jelly casting magnesis and
holding an item will drop it at link's
feet immediately faster than tossing it
normally then you know what's coming
this whole plan comes together in a mere
10 seconds
[Music]
so to summarize all this he pre-prepared
a mark behind the guardian has an
incoming arrow volley on the way and has
a chuchu jelly ready behind him then
starts charging a spin attack to take
the guardian head on but as planned his
pre-fired normal arrow comes in and
stuns the poor guardian in the eye to
cancel its laser and at the same time
performs the spin attack backwards to
perform a perfectly timed backwards
jelly bounce immediately into an atr he
pans the camera for an epic moment and
both atr's right through the guardian
and strikes his eye with an instant kill
ancient arrow at the same time the order
of events was literally frame perfect as
the flurry rush slow down wears off he
watches a rag dalian guardian explode
into oblivion bang shotting off of
calamity gannon's pillar the place it
was initially created from for good
measure the irony is too good
this 20 second clip has so much work put
into it and just shows how far a
committed breath of the wild player will
continue to push this 5 year old game
just when you think there's nothing else
to do there's a new ceiling for players
to try and break through it really is
never ending a big thank you to brad
neko for sharing this and if you enjoyed
this breakdown let us know with a like
and like usual for all of your other
gaming needs keep it here on gamespot
[Music]
you